so the hotel laundry industry if you've
never really thought about it is
enormous
in New York there's about 800 hotels or
123 thousand hotel rooms each hotel room
were somebody staying there generates at
least 10 pounds of laundry a day it ends
up being you know probably a few hundred
million pounds of laundry just in New
York back in the old days the maids
would just do the laundry in the
basement but over time it's shifted and
there's all of these big commercial
laundries that do the laundry for the
hotels it doesn't look like your
standard laundromat with a little you
know washer and you put your towels in
and they come out clean these are giant
commercial tunnel washers they're 65
feet long they cost up to fourteen
million dollars and this looks more like
a factory there is great concern this
morning was another hideous day on Wall
Street on markets of plunging because of
the corona virus pandemic what does that
mean for America's biggest city a few
months ago when I was reporting this
story the hotel industry was booming in
New York City hotels were at ninety
percent occupancy levels but in the wake
of the corona virus outbreak the travel
and hospitality industries are getting
hit badly Hotel occupancies in New York
are cratering and that's meant less
dirty laundry for companies to clean in
New York City the occupancy rate
throughout the year is usually around
ninety eight percent during 9/11
occupancies for the hotels dropped to
its lowest and it was 78 percent during
the coronavirus occupancies have hit 10
percent alone so what we're doing now is
picking up absolutely nothing we're just
dropping off empty bins hoping that we
pick up anything if anything
Yacouba jazzy who's the president of
star laundry first came to my attention
through our 30 under 30 process he was a
nominee in the manufacturing and
industry category and I was immediately
struck by his nomination because he's 27
years old he's running a business that
has over a hundred million in revenue
over 400 people working for him that is
not typical for our 30 under 30 s so
Jakub is quite young he's 27 now and he
was much younger when he took over the
business
his father quite sadly had passed away
when he was 19 and Jakub decided that he
was going to ditch school and take over
the business at the time the business
was very small and it was not doing well
at all and Jakob wanted to fix it to
just sort of to save his father's
reputation and build something bigger
and little by little he managed to do
that he he turned around the finances
and built it into the largest laundry in
New York so we're trying to get Hospital
contracts but there are two major
players in the laundry industry that
only work with hospitals what I'm
hearing now is certain hotel properties
are gonna turn into hospitals so
Marriott and Hilton are bidding against
each other
to try to get those contracts so if
hotels start converting into hospitals
I'm sure they'll need sanitary linen
daily for us to pick up and drop off
which we are capable of doing since we
use such high heat and an abundance of
chemicals that sanitizes the link if
star laundry can work with these hotels
as they potentially transform into
hospital outpost the company may fare
better than expected in the coming
months and for the moment the normally
competitive industry is trying to work
together I feel that this is one very
humbling especially for us and our
competition everybody's starting to
realize that the war we had against each
other doesn't really mean anything
anymore so we've had conversations with
our competitors as well too
look for a way to simplify things all
across the board
I believe when things do pick back up a
lot of things will be a lot easier with
hiring employees pricing hotels out what
type of I guess service we're gonna be
providing to the hotels if there's
things that have to change this allows
us to reevaluate everything all the
hotel staff and properties understand
what everybody's going through so
everybody will send emails to each other
just keeping spirits alive and checking
you on each other which is great given
the circumstance it's horrible what's
going on but it's it's actually good to
see everybody getting together so that's
it's a good thing to see it's not clear
how long it will take for the pandemic
to end or for people to feel safe
traveling and staying in hotels that's
going to require a major adjustment for
companies like Star